investigators searching for a missing
college student in Iowa hoped that a
trail of electronic data will help find
her
Molly Tibbets is her name she's a
sophomore at the University of Iowa she
vanished last week after going on a run
Adriana Diaz is in Brooklyn Iowa with
how the woman's fitness tracker and cell
phone may provide clues about her
disappearance Adriana good morning good
morning
Tibbits face is all over town there are
missing signs posted on nearly every
storefront when she disappeared she was
wearing a Fitbit fitness tracker like
this one investigators say that's
critical because this holds a trove of
data about her movements the day she
vanished she is out there somewhere and
we need to bring her back home Kim
Calderwood says her 20 year old niece
Molly Tibbets is a fighter and a force
of nature do you talk to her in your
mind absolutely every day on my way to
work what do you say to her I love you
sweet girl love you we will not give up
on you and don't you give up on us when
she vanished last Wednesday Tibbits
likely had her cellphone and a Fitbit on
her wrist to track her run says mich
Mort FET of the Iowa Division of
Criminal Investigation we're hoping to
be able to precisely examine and know
where she was when she was there the
pace she was running walking jogging
heart rate anything that that's kind of
stuff monitors investigators have built
a detailed timeline of her movements
before she disappeared based on
eyewitness accounts cell phone tower
pings her Fitbit data and social media
activities they don't think she returned
home that night but they also don't
think she ran away could someone have
tracked her movements on social media
potentially have stalked her I think in
today's world that's definitely a
possibility
Tibbits boyfriend Dalton Jack opened a
snapchat message from her the night she
disappeared
she'd started her run from his house
where she was dog sitting her boyfriend
was out of town and is not a suspect
just kind of putting trust and faith in
the law enforcement and he has this
message for his girlfriend
we love you we're looking for you we're
never stop police have issued warrants
to social media companies to get tip its
account data and there are at least a
dozen FBI agents here analyzing that and
other information as for her cell phone
and her Fitbit police believe they've
been turned off or their out of battery
but they keep checking in case they're
turned back on Norah
Adriana thank you why I hope they find
how I do too let's hope that electronic
trail pays off this is a family remember
you have to keep hoping you can't give
up great